Recall the basic idea of
how a two-way merge works.
You're initially given a bunch of input
runs, each of, let's say, the same size,
and each one sorted in ascending order.
Your goal is to produce
a single sorted output.
A natural scheme, based on the classical
merge sort idea is to take pairs of runs
and combine them in a tree-like fashion.
One problem with two way merging is that
it doesn't really use fast memory to its
fullest potential.
Remember how merging and
fast memory works?
At any point in time it uses very little
of the available fast memory space.
In fact it uses just
three L-sized blocks.
There's one block for each of A and
B, and one block for the output C.
So can you do better?
A natural idea is to merge
not two runs at a time, but
a bunch of runs, let's say K.
In fact, let's start by considering
one of these K way merges.
You're given a set of K input runs,
each of size S.
Let's say they start in slow memory and
they're sorted in ascending order.
Let's also suppose that you've
chosen this value of K so
that at least K plus one blocks
of L will fit in fast memory.
Your choice of K is not arbitrary.
Let's say you've chosen it so
that K plus one L-sized blocks
will fit in fast memory.
This way you can reserve one block for
each of the inputs, as well as
an additional block for the output.
Initially, you would fill the inputs
with blocks of the input runs.
Now at each step of the local merge,
you need to know which of the K input
blocks has the next smallest item.
Let's say that these shaded items
are the next ones to consider from
each of the K input blocks.
Of these,
you need to somehow find the smallest.
Let's say that's this item.
We'll come back to precisely how
to find it in just a moment.
You can move this smallest
item to the output buffer.
The next item from the source
buffer now becomes active.
You then repeat this process.
For instance, maybe this first
block has the next smallest item.
So move it and
make the item that follows it active.
As with two way merge, you will at
some point fill the output block.
When that happens you
just need to flush it.
Similarly, you will at some point
exhaust one of the input buffers.
Again, if there are any unread
blocks of the input that remain,
you just refill it.
Now let's return to the question
how should you pick the next
smallest item from the input frontier?
You have several natural options.
For instance,
one simple way is to do a linear scan.
This is fine if K is small.
Otherwise, you might consider some
type of priority queue data structure,
like say a min-heap.
Let's say we go with a min-heap.
You would then have
the following operational costs.
After loading the first K blocks,
you'd have to build the heap,
which would cost you O of K operations.
Then anytime you wanted to
find the next item to merge,
you'd call an extract Min,
which would cost you log K operations.
And after you extract an item,
you might need to replace it, which
would also have a logarithmic cost.
Now remember,
these are all fast memory operations, so
when we consider these costs,
we'll just count them as comparisons.
Now, assuming a heap-based
implementation,
what's the cost of a single K way merge?
Let's start with slow-fast
memory transfers.
You only ever read distinct
input blocks once, and
you only ever write distinct
output blocks once.
So that's 2Ks over L block reads and
writes.
What about comparisons?
First, there's the initial
cost to build the heap,
Then every one of the K times s items is
eventually either inserted or extracted.
Since each insert or extract
costs you O of log K comparisons,
then that's an additional asymptotic
cost of about Ks log K comparisons.
Remember, that's for
a single k-way merge.
Now's a good time to pause before
seeing what happens in the full K-way
merge tree.